[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I was a young gymnast,
I was exactly like you.
I had a lot of love and
passion for this sport,
but little Simone, she just
flailed her body in the air
and just thought it was the
greatest thing of all time.
And I needed to
work on my technique
and fundamental
skills to improve.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whenever I was
younger, I was always
the type of gymnast to be,
like, lollygagging around.
And I'm like, oh my god,
it's my turn, let's go.
I learned discipline
inside the gym.
In this MasterClass, I want
to show you the fundamentals,
from basics to advanced skills.
I will also demonstrate more
advanced and elite skills.
Initiate your twist
with your feet,
then hips, then shoulders.
No matter what skill you
execute off the table,
it's really important to block
first, rise, and then twist.
ANNOUNCER: Now on uneven
bars, Simone Biles.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Honestly, right there, I
was thinking don't screw up.
I'm literally
terrified right now.
I'm already struggling, and
you can see I'm rushing.
My hands weren't completely
placed on the bars.
You always have to go through
and finish whatever performance
you're doing.
If you're not nervous once
you go out to compete,
then something's wrong.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Keep working hard in the gym.
Communicate what you
want from your coaches.
And always remember, that these
things don't happen overnight.
It takes a lot of work
to get to where we are.
But with practice
and confidence,
you can accomplish
your dreams, too.
I'm Simone Biles, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]